Time magazine reports the fakest news of
the year the oscars may not have any
host at all and Chuck and Nancy make a
huge mistake during an explosive oval
office meeting finally a heartwarming
moment at a Nashville Airport on this is
America
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Noel's show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the mainstream media Time magazine has
decided that for the person of the year
they are going to select the mainstream
media here they are
it is violence fear and lies we don't
have the luxury to lose our freedom what
are you gonna stand for what is the line
that you don't cross the guardians the
war on truth jamal Khashoggi and
basically anyone who doesn't like donald
trump we will explain why the mainstream
media continues to be distrusted why
everybody just despises them and why
they are the most self-aggrandizing
people on planet earth but first let's
talk about keeps this is very important
losing your hair is a terrible thing you
don't realize how much you care about it
until you start losing it which is why
you should be using keeps the easiest
and most affordable way to keep the hair
you have when Drew and I when drew
Clavin and I go to bars to pick up
chickies you know it'll three or four
nights a week I got to tell you he still
does better than I do but it's cuz he's
a famous author and screenwriter the
reason that I do well at all is because
I have all of this luscious hair I'm not
an Adonis of a man the best thing I've
got going for me in that department is
my big head of hair and these FDA proof
products which used to cost a ton of
money now thanks to keeps our finally
inexpensive they're easy to get for five
minutes now just a dollar a day you will
never have to worry about hair loss
again a lot of guys start losing their
hair between 25 35 years old it starts
really young you can keep the hair that
you have you just need to start right
now and it's so inexpensive keeps offers
generic versions of the only two
fda-approved hair loss products out
there some of you might have tried them
before but you've never gotten done for
this price it's 10 to 35 bucks a month
now you can get your first month 3 one
heck of a deal for keeping your hair to
receive your first month of treatment
for free do it now young gentlemen
especially go to keeps calm / go F FA CE
o VF e f e ke EPS calm / cough FA Co V
Fe Fe that's a free month of treatment
I'm giving you stuff Merry Christmas
keeps calm / khofifah Co V Fe Fe keeps
hair today hair tomorrow the time Person
of the Year I woke up today and I knew I
knew it was going to be a fun show I
just knew
I looked I always look right when I wake
up I look at the news Person of the Year
Jamal khashoggi but not just jamocha
you'll remember Jamal khashoggi is the
Islamist former Saudi insider who was
brutally killed truly brutally killed by
the Saudi regime in an embassy in Turkey
and the mainstream media tried to paint
this guy as a liberal Western democratic
reformer journalist total bunk and they
made him the Person of the Year and all
of the Guardians the mainstream media
the defenders of truth the most
fictional group of people I've ever
heard of in my life here is how the the
piece begins quote the stout man with
the gray goatee and the gentle demeanor
dared to disagree with his country's
government talking about Jamal khashoggi
he told the world the truth about its
brutality toward those who would speak
out and he was murdered for it every
detail of Jamal khashoggi skilling made
it a sensation virtually nothing about
that statement is true he's a stout man
with a gray goatee and a gentle demeanor
I'm not sure about this he regularly
propagandized for Hamas he was a
defender and a member certainly at one
time and maybe for his entire life of
the Muslim Brotherhood
he didn't just dare to disagree with his
country's government the Saudi
government has been brutal has been
vicious has murdered dissonance has
trampled on human rights for a very very
long time and for most of the time that
the Saudi government was doing it Jamal
khashoggi was helping them to do it he
was a Saudi insider he was a royal
advisor he was a spy for the Saudi
government it was only when a new
faction of the Saudi regime came to
power that he fell out of favor and the
mainstream media painted him as this
democratic reformer he never ever was
that it is simply a lie there are photos
of him holding assault rifles in
Afghanistan when he was there with Osama
bin Laden in the 80s this is not a
gentle guy who happened to finally blow
the whistle on the excesses of his
government everybody knows how awful the
Saudi regime is and Jamal khashoggi
helped helped them in their excesses he
helped the regime until his side of the
government fell out of power and
ironically actually the new side of
the Saudi government run by Mohammed bin
Salman is much more reforming ISM as
much friendlier toward Western powers
and Western interests one of the jamal
khashoggi x' major complaints against
the saudi regime was they were too nice
to Israel they were dealing with Israel
too much it shouldn't be so nice to all
those Jews
Jamal Khashoggi also blamed the United
States for bringing 9/11 on itself very
few people have written about this but
Jamal khashoggi in the wake of 9/11 said
quote Saudis tend to link the ugliness
of what happened in New York and
Washington with what has happened and
continues to happen in Palestine
that's a fictional country but between
Wakanda and Narnia it is time that the
United States comes to understand the
effect of its foreign policy and the
consequences of that policy but
unfortunately such rationalization is
still not part of the American reality
saying this is the consequence of
supporting Israel is that Muslim
terrorists fly planes into your
buildings and kill 3,000 civilians
that's what Jamal khashoggi said the
democratic wonderful reformer American
resident he wasn't even a permanent
resident this is what they're trying to
make it out this is Time magazine's
Person of the Year what is the real
story behind khashoggi we've said a
number of aspects of it before worth
pointing out he was officially a royal
advisor he traveled with King Abdullah
for the previous king of the of the
Kingdom he was very close with Prince
Turki al-faisal that's how we know that
he likely very likely worked as a Saudi
spy in 2015 this all turned around
because King Salman rose to power and
Mohammed bin Salman became the heir
apparent the crown prince of the kingdom
what why does the mainstream media
jumped to elevate this guy look I'm
actually not defending his killing some
people have accused me of defending the
killing of Jamal khashoggi I'm not doing
that at all it's awful to kill people in
embassies and chop them up while they're
alive I'm not defending that what I'm
saying is when you play around with
awful regimes when you're a close
advisor to awful regimes when you
support Islamist movements throughout
the Middle East and radical Islamism
when you weep over the death of Osama
bin Laden you're known by the friends
you keep in bad thing
might happen to you that's what that's
my entire thesis on Jamal khashoggi so
why is the mainstream media defending
him so much in part this is just a side
war in defending Barack Obama and
attacking Donald Trump Barack Obama
tried to cozy up to Iran Donald Trump is
protecting our alliance with Saudi
Arabia as a as a power that is contrary
to Iran Donald Trump ripped up the Iran
nuclear deal Donald Trump is standing by
the Saudis as a as a stave against
Iranian hegemony in the region so that's
what a little bit of what's going on
with the mainstream media now the Time
magazine article doesn't get everything
wrong it names a few real journalists -
name's Maria Ressler
who is a journalist in the Philippines
covering the duterte regime she might go
to jail for doing her job obviously
that's a real journalist they cover a
capitol newspaper in Maryland and they
Capitol newspaper you'll remember they
had those five staffers gunned down in
June but even covering this which is you
know it was such an awful shooting that
happened there Time magazine is covering
it to attack Donald Trump listen to what
they write quote in Annapolis Maryland
staff of the Capitol a newspaper
published by Capitol Gazette
communications which traces its history
of telling readers about the events in
Maryland - before the American
Revolution press on without the five
colleagues gunned down in their newsroom
on June 28th still intact
indeed strengthened after the mass
shooting are the bonds of trust and
community that for national news outlets
have been eroded on strikingly partisan
lines never more than this year what an
astounding statement to say what what
the Time magazine is doing here is
accusing Republicans of being
responsible for the shooting in Maryland
which which has no basis in reality and
even their line that that trust of
American news outlets has broken down on
partisan lines isn't true the majority
of Americans Democrats independents and
Republicans distrust the mainstream
media the majority of Democrats - it is
not eroded on strikingly partisan lines
that is fake news that is just as fake
news is calling Jamal khashoggi
a Western liberal reformer journalist
and making him person of the year there
were a couple other real reporters - two
reporters for Reuters in Myanmar were
thrown in jail for documenting the
deaths of Rohingya people there they're
named in the article okay
Bangladeshi photographer was jailed for
a hundred days for criticizing the Prime
Minister so that they're what they do
they're so smart about this is they mix
in real journalists who are actually
being persecuted for shedding light on
corrupt governments they're mixing that
in with fake news stories to attack
Donald Trump to try to pretend that a
Bangladeshi photographer being thrown in
jail for criticizing the Prime Minister
is the same thing as Jim Acosta
grandstanding and not giving up the
microphone and not letting other
reporters ask questions losing his Press
Pass for five minutes that's what
they're trying to do and they're trying
to compare a Saudi spy insider Islamist
who wants the whole Middle East to be
run by an Islamic theocracy and who
wants Israel blown off the map they're
trying to make him seem like some
wonderful Western journalist he's out
there you know working the beat for The
Washington Post
unbelievably not true the you know if
Time magazine really wanted to put
journalists up front which they can
especially international journalists who
actually are up against corrupt regimes
lead with them lead with those guys but
they don't lead with them they lead in
their video in their story they lead
with Donald Trump and Jamal khashoggi
just know no credibility at all what are
the takeaways here obviously the
mainstream media have a very
overinflated view of themselves
the other takeaway is that the only
unifying theme right now on the left is
hatred of Donald Trump that's
all--that's unifying them they can't
pick some activists or some politician
or some businessman who would be Person
of the Year all they can do is take the
opponent of Donald Trump which is the
lying media like Time magazine and say
that's the person of the year it's all
about Trump
he's living rent-free in their heads and
then what it shows is this obliviousness
of the mainstream media they're saying
that Republicans hate the media and
Trust is at an all-time low but
Democrats love the media that isn't true
trust in the media is at an all-time low
according to Axio SurveyMonkey the
majority of Americans believe 72%
believe quote traditional major news
outlets report news they know to be fake
false or purposely misleading a huge
majority of Americans 92 percent of the
GOP 79 percent of independents and 53
percent of Democrats even the majority
of Democrats think that major mainstream
news outlets knowingly lie and present
fake news and this didn't just start
with Trump this is a long trend we'll
look at it in a second but first come on
into my boudoir baby and let's talk
about purple mattress you know about
purple mattress I've told you about them
I have I have back problems my family
has back problems I always have never
found a bed that I truly love until this
one this bed purple mattress I may
proselytize ur for them it is so good
the founders of purple are two brothers
they've been developing this cushioning
technology for 30 years and it's it's
different than any other bed it will
feel different because it's not memory
foam exactly it's not an innerspring it
is this material developed by a rocket
scientist it is both firm and soft at
the same time how is that possible I
can't tell you I'm not a rocket
scientist I just talk into a camera all
day but it really does work it's so good
it sleeps cool it's I just cannot
recommend it enough right now you will
get a hundred night risk-free trial if
you're not fully satisfied you can
return your mattress for a full refund
back by 10 year warranty free shipping
and returns you won't need to return it
it's that good free in-home set up and
old mattress removal you are gonna love
purple right now my listeners will get a
free purple pillow with the purchase of
a mattress say that five times fast in
addition to the great free gifts
offering site-wide just text do this
right now pull over stop your car throw
into park text cough fac OVF efe - 47 47
47 that is the only way to get this free
pillow text offa COV fe fe - 47 47 47 c
OB fe fe 47 47 47 message and data rates
may apply you don't get that for free
but you could get a free pillow this
didn't
begin there's a distrust in the media
this didn't begin with Donald Trump
people want to say well yes people
distrust the media now because Trump is
using the bully pulpit of the presidency
to attack the media every day no way it
goes back way before Trump it goes back
to before Barack Obama was the president
a 2008 Princeton survey showed just how
far trust in the media had fallen
according to one survey in 1956 the
strong majority of Americans thought
that newspapers were fair 66 percent of
Americans thought the newspapers were
fair by 2004 10 % of Americans had a
great deal of confidence in the press 66
percent down to 10 percent that is a
massive drop-off the media did this to
themselves the media did this to
themselves because they lied because
they were hacks because they carried
water for their favored politicians and
they pretended that they were objective
if they were just pushing aside if they
were activists if they had a point of
view if they were giving commentary or
pundit or a or opinion or whatever well
I do that I I have a side I have an
opinions about the world I have a
particular viewpoint I'm honest about
that and if they were to do that I
highly suspect that their their approval
ratings and their their trust in them
would not have brought so much but it
certainly did so who should be the
person of the year who should get it I I
was really upset because I think it was
People magazine decided that Michael B
Jordan was the sexiest Michael of the
year and then Michael avenatti was
number two or something like that are
you kidding me I get it I get it that
I'm not Michael B Jordan okay I'm
willing I'm self-aware enough Michael
avenatti
I don't beat up Michael ever not real
nice guys but we're not talking about
the sexiest person of the year we're
talking about the the Time magazine
Person of the Year who should get it
there are a few options if they wanted
to do this sort of dissident theme if
they wanted to do this someone's
speaking truth to power being unfairly
targeted by those in power okay then
they should have really made it the
dissident and they should have made it
conservatives on social media all of the
conservatives who are being banned
censored thrown out
by social media and it's not just Alex
Jones and the shirtless vitamin salesman
and the gay frogs it's not just that
it's Gavin McGinnis conservative
comedian has been thrown off of YouTube
has been thrown off of his platforms
Jesse Kelly who's a totally mainstream
guy congressional candidate radio host
he was kicked off until the outcry was
so large it should be conservatives on
social media that would be a that's a
real dissident not Jim Acosta or Saudi
regime insiders that's a real dissident
if they wanted to do another group one
and they don't want to do the dissident
because frankly you know the dissident
thing has been done who could they have
done if they were going to do a good
group one it probably should be the
American worker they do this sometimes
sometimes they'll pick individual people
then sometimes they will pick you know
you in 2006 it was you because of
YouTube and the rise of social media
they should have done this year for a
group Person of the Year the American
worker the American workers is doing
better right now than he has done in
decades
his real wages are going up his real
income is going up unemployment
basically does not exist there are more
jobs to fill than people to fill them
right now this is especially true of at
black unemployment black unemployment is
at record lows Hispanic unemployment has
plunged the American worker is doing
very well why is the American worker
doing well because the economy is doing
well under President Trump as people are
allowed to keep more of their money and
invest more of their money in the
economy and because the the president
has taken measures to fight trade wars
that we are already in we are already in
a trade war with China President Trump
is defending American workers against
those that trade war against the
assaults by the Chinese government on
the American worker even with some of
our allies you know America's hat Canada
they have their protective tariffs but
they don't want us to have our
protective tariffs they want to protect
their workers but they don't want us to
protect our workers president Trump has
gone in and and renegotiated some of
those trade deals and this was a big
benefit it's a big benefit to the worker
we'll see in the long run how this fares
for the economy I think we're on the
longest bull run in history or something
like that
running historically long bull run for
the markets so eventually there will be
a correction but that would have been a
good group
effort for the person of the year the
real individual of the year because I
don't think that there should be group
persons of the year that we're talking
about the person of the year we're
talking about individuals who have done
important things in the year and define
the year is Brett Kavanaugh
he is the person of the year he showed
more than anybody the fault lines in
American politics you have an
unimpeachable dignified federal judge
for a dozen years impeccable credentials
and the left was so furious that their
fictitious constitutional right to an
abortion might be threatened possibly by
a change in the swing of the court that
they tried to paint Brett Kavanaugh to
be a gang rapist based on nothing based
on less than nothing and some of the
people who made those false claims
against him are now being criminally
investigated Brett Kavanaugh should be
the person of the year what he endured
what he showed about the significance of
presidential elections and how elections
have consequences what he has shown us
about the Constitution and what the
Constitution means for the judiciary and
what it means for our system of
government and what what he showed about
how how far and how low the left is
willing to go to attack American
constitutional governments that guy is
the person of the year but he won't get
it there instead going to give it to a
Saudi spy Islamist friend of Osama bin
Laden and to Jim Acosta basically okay
speaking of things that are equally
frivolous as Jim Acosta and the American
mainstream media the Oscars might not
have any host at all so you know the
Oscars they had this big blowup because
they selected Kevin Hart who's a
comedian to be the host of the Oscars
and then they attacked him for a 10-year
old joke a joke he told 10 years ago
about how he didn't want his son to be
gay and he is now out so now no comedian
who's ever told a gay joke can be the
host of the Oscars which is every single
comedian so there is no comedian that
they can do now they have a suggestion
that they're not gonna have any one host
they're gonna have a bunch of different
little people come up and do little bits
of the show this is a horrible idea it
totally typifies leftism but just to
show you how insane it was to kick out
Kevin Hart because we've all read about
the the
comedy routine that he did about his gay
son no I didn't want his son to be gay
we all read it and we say oh that's not
funny oh that's not no no no here is the
actual clip from the comedy special of
Kevin Hart's joke this is why the Oscars
will not have a host this year the Finn
is talking I turn him back around to
check out my son again
a little boy was grinding on my son he
was like this I didn't know what to do I
panicked I'm not the boat man it's
important to watch it because when we
read the news reports this is how
they're reported they say and then Kevin
Hart said he knocked his son and the
other boy to the ground and he said he
yelled at him don't be gay no he did a
comedy routine in a movie he did a
comedy special in his stand-up comedy
show because he's a comedian you really
you don't hear the laughs when you read
it so back then ten years ago going that
long those halcyon years of the 2000s
Kevin Hart did this bit and the audience
loved it of course it's a funny bit
people like it now but now we all have
to pretend that it's not funny and what
is the joke about the joke is about how
much the culture has changed so much of
comedy depends on incongruity so you
have our present culture which is so gay
affirming that there there is almost no
greater good than gay sex gay
relationships when the Supreme Court
invented the the new definition of
marriage because of Justice Kennedy
Barack Obama didn't just say good
decision he painted the White House in
rainbow light colors that's how
affirming our culture is of gay
relationships in gay sex and what Kevin
Hart is doing is comparing that to
people's natural reaction to that he
says as a heterosexual male what he's
comparing it to is every other culture
and religion in the history of the
entire world which has held
homosexuality and homosexual acts in
moral opprobrium and what he's saying is
even at the top he says look I'm not
homophobic I want people to be to have
it doing whatever they want and have a
good time and have a good life but I
know that intellectually but deep down
in this visceral part of me I don't want
my son to be gay
that's the joke yeah it actually
wouldn't work if he were just going on
some diatribe about how he hates gay
people that wouldn't be a joke it would
just be a diatribe
he's setting up the joke with the
juxtaposition of those two things and
that's why people are laughing but now
we're not allowed to laugh at jokes
because that's not funny because it's
that meme of Sandra Fluke the the
Democrat abortion activist you know the
one of her with her arms crossed if
that's not funny
so Kevin Hart is out now they are saying
that they're not going to have any host
and this is that the typical cowardice
of our day and age this is it this
completely embodies it everyone is so
afraid of asserting anything that we
need to be everything to everybody and
especially the left we want to be
everything to everybody don't box me in
don't pin me down don't call me don't
ask me if I think this or I think this
where I believe in this or I believe in
that don't call me a conservative don't
call me a Christian don't say I think
don't make me think or say that I
believe or this or that I just feel like
I just oh don't box me and don't pin me
down I don't exactly like this I don't
support this politician I'm a Republican
but not that kind of Republican
conservative but not that guy it's this
wanting to please every we're so
desperate that you can't do that because
particularity can be pinned down when
you pin somebody down you are making an
assertion you are at which is a manly
thing to do it's a manly thing to assert
something that you think on the world
well we will not do that now anyone for
this is why whenever they have
presidential candidates they'll say the
generic Democrat is gonna beat Donald
Trump okay
fine maybe but there's no such thing as
a generic Democrat there are only
individual Democrats who are running for
office against Donald Trump and none of
them are polling better than Trump it's
only the generic in in the Hillary
Clinton when she was Secretary of State
she was the hypothetical candidate
Hillary Clinton right she was no no
issues no campaign addresses yet no she
had she didn't say where she stood on
all of these issues she was just
hypothetical candidate Hillary and her
approval ratings were very high the
minute she declared that she was running
for office
and she said I think this I believe this
I want to do this I'm gonna do that her
approval ratings plummeted particularity
pins people down this is why we can't
say Merry Christmas it's the same reason
you can't say what but particular it
could be offensive you just say holidays
there's only one holiday it's not
hanukkah's way earlier the new year is
in the new year Kwanzaa is a socialist
contrivance that nobody celebrates it's
just Christmas you say you can't say
Christmas it's too particular you have
to be vague we have to be vague about
everything where does this come from
this comes from an unrealistic view of
the world that's what this really comes
from this comes from a world view that
is bereft of grace and forgiveness and
tolerance and the appreciation of
diversity within the world this that
world view begets this sort of thing
where any any individual comedian now
that they put up there will not be
acceptable
no no comedian has not made a gay joke
no person has not made a gay joke not no
straight person no gay person no human
being on the face of the earth has not
made or laughed at a gay joke so now
they have an impossible standard that
they have to live up to what the left
doesn't understand is that everybody is
fallen everybody everybody is imperfect
you can always find something you can
always find that one little tweet that
the Heisman Trophy winner sent ten years
ago when he was 12 and you can rip him
to shreds because of that but what kind
of society is that is that the society
that you want to live in that's left is
emporia custody and they hate diversity
but the left for you is no grace no
particularity no diversity and no humor
that's that's the world they're offering
do you want that world did you want
something else I want something else and
nowhere was this exhibited more clearly
demonstrated for all the world to see on
the biggest stage in the whole world
then in this bombshell amazing press
conference between President Trump vice
president pence leader Pelosi and leader
Schumer an already leader Chuck Schumer
they were all there they were just
discussing the spending bill they were
talking about border secure
and Nancy Pelosi made one of the classic
blunders I'll let her show you herself I
think the American people recognized
that we must keep government open that a
shutdown is not worth anything
and that you should not have a trunk
shutdown you have trouble you have a
White House critical you have the Senate
you have the House of Representative you
have the vote you should pass know we
have the vodka to because in the Senate
we need 60 right yeah but I can't excuse
me but I can't get it passed in the
house if it's not gonna pass in the
Senate I don't wanna waste but well the
fact is you can get it started that way
the house we could get passed very easy
okay we do but the problem is the Senate
because we need 10 Democrats to vote the
point is is that their equities to be
weighed and we're here to have a
conversation for a careful way so I
don't think we should have a debate in
front of the press on this but the fact
is the sent the House Republicans could
bring up this bill if they had the votes
immediately and set the tone for what
you want oh this is what they always do
this is what the left always does
they pick a fight and then they can't
win the fight and then they tell you
that they don't want to fight I did I
saw this at politican I was on stage at
politican there were all these lefties
on stage they they make some stupid
point they throw out some stupid attack
I knocked down the attack and then they
say stop we're not talking about that
yeah you don't want to talk about it not
you five seconds ago you wanted to talk
about it now you don't because you don't
know anything and we've just embarrassed
you that's what happened here with with
Nancy Pelosi and Donald Trump Nancy
Pelosi made an error so egregious I
actually don't there must be something
wrong with her she thought that she
could beat Donald Trump in a game of
reality television
she can't maybe she can beat him at a
legislative maneuver maybe she can beat
him at a sort of political speech kind
of whatever she will never beat Donald
Trump at reality television
Donald Trump is reality television and
she decided that during this nice little
press conference
she was gonna throw a bomb down and say
that the government shutdown would be a
trump shutdown and Donald Trump isn't do
you think you can surprise him on
television do you actually think that
you can you're gonna win a game of The
Real Housewives with Donald Trump or The
Apprentice or Jersey Shore no chance he
knows every camera angle he knows every
response it's just not gonna work but
the other thing that's at play here is
that Nancy Pelosi is living in an old
political world she is living in the
political world of 2009-2010 she's
living in this political world where and
I I know it cuz I've worked on these
campaigns and I've seen the focus groups
and I've seen all the testing what you
do is you focus test certain phrases so
you focus tests Trump shut down or you
focus tests you know you have the votes
right she keeps trying to say that he
has the votes to pass his border funding
which he doesn't he doesn't have the
Senate but you focus test those lines
and then you see how they perform and
then you just repeat them on TV even if
they don't make any sense you repeat
them and they get into the popular
consciousness the reason this doesn't
work anymore is because President Trump
is an improvisor president Trump is
ad-libbing he's really light on his feet
so he can knock it down and because he
doesn't take the typical care of the
office he doesn't take typical care of
how the the cameras are perceiving him
he'll just shut her up on the spot I'll
say what are you talking about I don't
have the votes I don't have the Senate
say well you have the votes you my
advisers gave me this sheet and said you
have the I don't at Nancy where do I
have the votes I don't have the Senate
what are you talking about so she goes
on with this
she obviously the shutdown thing didn't
work very well so then they start going
back and forth over the wall and still
she gets it Chuck Schumer for you know
for his part actually knows to stick out
of this one because he knows that Pelosi
is losing and the Trump is winning so
for the first time in Chuck Schumer's
entire life he keeps his mouth zipped
here they are talking about the wall but
there are no votes in the house a
majority of votes for a wall no matter
what we write you know if I needed the
votes for the wall in the house
would have them in one session would be
done
it doesn't help because we need 10
Democrats and okay let me ask you this
just and we're doing this in a very
friendly manner
it doesn't help for me to take a vote in
the house where I will win easily with
the Republicans it doesn't help to take
that vote because I'm not going to get
the vote of the Senate I need ten
senators that's I have the white house
the white house is done and the house
would give me the vote if I wanted it
but I can't because I need Nancy I need
10 votes from Chuck she keeps trying she
said what my focus tested lines you have
the White House you have the Senate you
have the Congress and no Nancy I don't I
don't have it you're right that I have
the White House and I have the House of
Representatives because other
politicians would not lower themselves
to engage in this bickering match with
Nancy Pelosi Donald Trump will and it's
to our benefit it is to the great
benefit of our country that he's willing
to get down there where Nancy Pelosi is
and go back and forth with her and it's
it is truly astounding the only people
heard out of Chuck Schumer is he says oh
that's right you know it's a Pelosi or
something but he's sticking out of this
one because he knows that Donald Trump
is gonna win over this and the other
aspect of Trump because he's willing to
assert himself he is the exact answer to
this cultural problem we have where were
unwilling to assert anything it's
probably why we've got Donald Trump is
nature abhors a vacuum and we're so
we're so used to this culture now nobody
willing to make any assertion the trunk
comes in and he will just put it right
on the table he uses very blunt language
and he he totally just refutes these
points a more polite person would say oh
well we agree to disagree the kind of
hey I hate to knock Jeb you know knock a
man when he's down but only a have been
down for two years but it is kind of the
Jeb answer of you know well I mean okay
well you know okay well agree to
disagree Trump no agree to disagree
you are wrong Nancy I am right we win
you lose hahaha a Chuck Schumer does get
in a pretty good jab here though and
it's worth pointing out because there's
another exchange with Chuck where they
both kind of get
they want we'll get to that in a second
plus we'll also get to brexit we'll get
to Google data collection and we will
get to a wonderful this is America
segment an actual uplifting moment but
first you got to go to daily wire.com if
you already there thank you you help
keep the lights on you keep Kofi Fei in
my cup if you are not there pay up
fork it over ten bucks a month $100 for
an annual membership you get me you get
the and reclaim and shout you get the
Ben Shapiro show you test questions in
the mailbag that's coming up on Thursday
get your questions in you test questions
in the conversation you get backstage
you got another Kingdom you get
everything man we're putting out more
than the network television these days
go do it most importantly you get the ax
leftist tears tumblr it's gonna be
really important when when you just put
it up right in front of your CNN screen
you take the lid off and you hear Nancy
Pelosi but you've got the White House
but you have the Congress but you have
the book why is it working why isn't
working you're gonna need your tumblr go
to daily we're calm we'll be right back
Chuck Schumer is much better at this
than Nancy Pelosi is obviously a Chuck
Schumer for all intents and purposes is
a television star the most dangerous
space in New York or Washington is the
area between Chuck Schumer and a TV
camera so he's well practiced at this -
he's a pretty impressive tactician in
the Senate and so he waits for his
moment and then he Springs on Trump and
this showdown was a little less clear I
think they actually both sort of got
what they wanted here but I'll I'll let
you decide one thing I think we can
agree on is we shouldn't shut down the
government over a dispute and you want
to shut it you shut it
no no no and then you okay it's all
right quickly and Winnie I don't want to
do what you did 20 times y'all have
called for I will shut down the
government if I don't get my wool none
of us have you wanna know so you've said
you want to put that who said it I'll
take it okay good you know what I'll say
yes
if we don't get what we want one way or
the other whether it's through you
through a military through anything you
want to call I will shut down the gun
okay absolutely no and I am proud and
agree I am proud to shut down the
government for border security Chuck
because the people of this country don't
want criminals and people that have lots
of problems and drugs pouring into our
country so I will take the mantle I will
be the one to shut it down I'm not gonna
blame you for it the last time you shut
it down it didn't work I will take the
medal of shutting down and I'm gonna
shut it down for border but we believe
you this was a pretty interesting little
chess match here if you just watch the
exchange Chuck Schumer sees his opening
he comes in and he says what we should
agree on is we don't want to shut down
the government
so he's establishing that premise I
don't know if I believe that premise
shut it down this is the only chance we
have to get border wall funding so shut
it down who cares when you shut down the
government only only essential services
are preserved non-essential services are
defunded which raises the question why
do we have non-essential services great
that's fine
shut it down it never lasts that long
and this is our last chance to get that
wall built so okay that's fine he
establishes that premise so that he can
then say you will be
sponsible if you shut down the
government so then Trump responds to
that he this is his Trump's a little
misstep here he says I won't be
responsible you shut down the government
Chuck I didn't shut down the government
you shut down the government and Chuck
Schumer sees that and he's already ready
to go with twenty times you promised
that you would shut down the government
so Schumer in setting up that premise
knows the Trump has already taken
responsibility for government shutdowns
and so he's gonna spring that on him and
it boxes Trump into a corner Trump made
that first misstep but then he realized
the misstep and I think he ultimately
won the exchange because he took the
strongest position which is shoot I
can't say that I'm not going to shut
down the government since I've already
said I'll shut it down so what I've got
to do is double down on it I will double
down on the assertion and I will tie it
to the security of our country so he
says you know what you're right I'll
take it
I will shut down the government for
border security and now Chuck Schumer
got what he wanted Chuck Schumer wanted
Trump to take responsibility for the
shutdown now they've got their their
clip for their television ads or
whatever they're gonna run and but what
Donald Trump gets is breaking out of
that political stasis that decrepit
status quo and saying you're right I'll
shut it down and I'll do it for border
security what Donald Trump is betting on
here is that the conventional wisdom is
wrong that government shutdowns aren't
that big a deal the public doesn't care
that much about them they don't they
aren't gonna blame Republicans for 50
years about them that it doesn't really
matter and he's betting that border
security is a very important issue for
Americans which we know that it is not
just among conservatives and Republicans
but among the left as well among
especially among independents so Schumer
got what he wanted and he's trying to
use this issue to scare some more
suburban voters who Donald Trump is
going to need in 2020 and what Donald
Trump gets out of it is border security
which while not as popular among the the
suburban housewives who are who that's
the Byward for moderate white people
that's the that's what we used and I was
saying Trump is losing moderate whites
they say he's losing suburban housewives
but that that issue does really play I
think that issue does play with the
silent majority with middle America
I think it plays with just about
everybody and a lot of polling back
setup so they both walk away with what
they wanted I think Trump ultimately
gets the better of that exchange but
Nancy Pelosi I mean you know you can't
teach a you can't teach a a set a house
minority leader who's been around for a
long time new tricks
how's that for diplomacy that's a little
nicer than what I was going to say so
she's probably not gonna learn it but
she should learn from President Trump
and Chuck Schumer because they're both
very good at this let's talk about this
brexit vote brexit is you remember
brexit they took the vote two years ago
there was a popular referendum among
Britons to leave the European Union it
it won the the brexit leave voters 152
to 48 it was a clear win it was a
decisive win two years later finally
Teresa Mae came to an agreement with
Brussels and with the the the European
Union but the the agreement is awful the
agreement does not achieve brexit it
leaves the UK subject to a lot of EU
regulations it leaves them subject to
the European Criminal Court there the
European Court of Justice rather it
leaves them in the customs union it
leaves them in a common rulebook it's
just a total fake so we were supposed to
vote on this deal today and it just
couldn't happen so here's Teresa May
saying the brexit isn't going to work
we've now had three days of debate on
the withdrawal agreement setting out the
terms of our departure from the EU and
the political declarations setting out
our future relationship after we have
left
I've listened very carefully to what has
been said in this chamber and out of it
[Applause]
- what has been said in this chamber and
out of it by members from all sides from
listening to those views it is clear
that while there is broad support for
many of the key aspects of the deal on
one issue on one issue the Northern
Ireland backstop there remains
widespread and deep concern as a result
if we went ahead and held the vote
tomorrow the deal would be rejected by a
significant margin we will therefore
defer the vote scheduled for tomorrow
and not proceed to divide the house at
this time you know the Brits really put
Trump and Nancy Pelosi into perspective
we talked about the decline of civility
but whenever you look at Parliament
they're always shouting and laughing and
screaming and making fun of whoever
speaking so she's saying that the brexit
isn't going to work we'll see what
happens now they're gonna either
renegotiate it or they're going to leave
the EU without a deal which in the short
run will be really hard it'll disrupt
air travel it will disrupt trade it will
disrupt a lot of things in the long run
I don't think it will matter that much
at all
or they're gonna try to push for another
referendum vote and just like the left
in America they'll just keep voting and
keep voting until they get the outcome
that they want the reason I bring it up
is to show just how dangerous these
transnational international unions can
be once you're in them it is virtually
impossible to get out of them and when
we consider things like the United
Nations or the International Criminal
Court or whatever you got once you enter
into these agreements it is virtually
impossible to get out of them that's why
our founding fathers all the way back to
George Washington and many other great
American leaders have been so wary about
entering into those entangling
arrangements Britain is figuring out
figuring that out right now
and we'll see if ultimately the will of
the people is going to be trampled by
bureaucrats who won't let them out
before we go on this this is America a
genuinely heartwarming moment at the
Nashville Airport a group of kids whose
parents were killed in combat who were
American servicemen was being flown to
Disney World as part of you know there
was a nice organization
these kids down to give them something
nice to look forward to and there was an
announcement over the loudspeaker that
they were coming through the airport and
everybody stopped and played the
national anthem and servicemen saluted
them and it's just a great video
[Music]
beautiful video it shows you what
happens when you don't just look at
yourself and you're not only wrapped up
in yourself and your own interests and
your own needs and you look at other
people what sort of compassion and
charity and sacrifice and suffering but
at least some community and suffering
some some moral interactions going on
what sacrifice means for for our freedom
for our country and what what it means
to love your country and to focus on
something outside of the self focus on
something greater and something that you
you really can love beautiful moment
obviously it's gonna be a hard Christmas
for these kids and just a really nice
exchange that didn't have to happen
but flowed naturally from people's love
of their country in their countrymen
really nice thing to see and a really
nice way to end so that we don't need to
end on Nancy Pelosi yapping about
nothing that's our show for today I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Noel's show come back tomorrow and I'll
see you again
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
semia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018